celebrations are also taking place here
in las vegas including in downtown
summerlin yeah bianca holman is there
live with a look at those festivities hi
bianca good morning
hey good morning alex good morning john
i heard you all talking about what your
chinese zodiac sign was and i found out
i was born in the year of the tiger and
so was hayley
so we are not celebrating our lunar new
year it's actually the year the ox this
year
tell me what do you all have planned
here in downtown summerland
so we're so excited to kick off lunar
new year starting tomorrow you download
the summerlin app we're doing lucky red
envelope giveaways filled with uh gift
cards so if you download that you'll get
all the details tomorrow
and then we have decor throughout the
entire property for the remainder of the
month so we have a brand new dragon
we have two photo ops at the macy's
promenade at h m hallway
and we just want to make it really
festive for the community this year yeah
so amazing so you know i know that we
have some performers out here
will we be able to see some of the
traditional performers throughout the
weekend
unfortunately we were unable to bring
the parade this year however if you are
here on friday and saturday evenings
you just might catch a little sneak peek
of some of our performers walking around
passing out those lucky red envelopes
that's so incredible and you all always
do a great job as far as honoring all
the cultures and holidays here
in las vegas because we have a little
bit of piece of all parts of the world
here in las vegas so
how are you just able to still you know
change with the times giving that we
have these social distancing
requirements
yeah so we really want to just make sure
that the community still has a way to
celebrate all the holidays and that
bringing them out to downtown summerlin
enjoying it whether it's photo ops decor
you know going out to eat with your
family you know just allowing the
the community to really come here as
place making and enjoy the holiday
incredible you all never disappoint and
also this weekend in addition to
celebrating the new moon and the lunar
new year
it's valentine's day right so what do
you all have planned for
the couples out there or maybe singles
awareness coming up next week and
galentine's for ladies who want to
celebrate with their friends a lot of
our restaurants and eateries will be
doing promotions all weekend long
whether you want to come and dine in or
you want to take it out and bring it
home
if you want all those details
summerlin.com all right great and so
again
we've got luna new year's celebrations
happening all across the valley
more details about what's happening
across the valley on our website at
8newsnow.com we're going to send it back
to you alec